The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So how many of you
have exposure or have taken
any heat transfer classes here?
OK, it's about half of you.
Cool so can you start by
telling me what heat is?
It's just like pretty basic.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, OK.
It's a form of energy.
What are the units of that?
AUDIENCE: Joules.
PROFESSOR: Cool.
And what about heat transfer?
What are-- I guess it's
pretty self-explanatory.
It's just transferring heat.
What are the units
of heat transfer?
Generally, you're trying to
figure out how much energy is
being transferred per second.
So you're going to have a
joule per second or watts.
Yeah.
So what are three major modes
of heat transfer as well?
How much do you remember?
AUDIENCE: Conduction,
convection, and radiation.
PROFESSOR: Awesome.
And for people who haven't
seen this material before,
tell me if I'm going
through it too quickly when
I started talking about it.
But can someone--
OK, can people explain what the
difference is between the three
types of heat transfer?
What?
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHS] I said I'm
giving someone else a shot.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Conduction is
just through direct contact.
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: Convention
is basically
conduction except through
a fluid that's moving.
PROFESSOR: Cool.
That's not how you spell it.
And radiation?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Photon emission.
PROFESSOR: I think it's
just more generally.
It's just heating through
electromagnetic waves.
But yeah, so that's
kind of the three sort
of big modes of heat transfer.
We'll be talking
about convection
and conduction a
lot more later when
we're doing, say, cooking
and stoves because that plays
into that a lot more, like, when
you're putting a pot on a fire.
When we're dealing
with solar stuff,
we're going to be dealing
mostly with radiation.
But while we're on
the topic of heat
or while we're on the
topic of heat transfer,
I might as well give you the
equations for the other two,
but we'll start by
talking about radiation.
So when we're dealing
with radiation, we're--
cool.
When we're dealing
with radiation,
we're thinking of
objects giving off energy
in electromagnetic waves.
The only thing
that really matters
when you're dealing with
this is what the temperature
of the object is.
So you can approximate
things as--
or there's an
equation for it, which
is the heat transfer
due to radiation
is the Stefan-Boltzmann
constant times the area
of the surface area of the
object times the temperature
to the fourth, which is an
important equation to know.
For convective heat transfer,
you have a different equation.
But again, this
isn't that relevant.
So I'm going to move on
to talking to you guys
about different types of
solar technologies now.
So the first one we are
going to talk about is SODIS.
Do you have any--
OK, so you have SODIS.
You have solar thermal.
So solar thermal is when--
there are different
types of technologies.
It's where you're using heat
from the sunlight directly.
So you're using solar
radiation to heat things.
And there are three
different sorts of big ways
you can do this.
You can use it for
cooking and drying.
heating of water,
and you can use it for
generating electricity.
And you also have photovoltaics,
which we worked with last time
for generating electricity.
So SODIS, the way SODIS works
is you fill bottles with water,
and you close the cap.
Then you leave these
bottles out on a rooftop,
and you expose them to
sunlight for about six hours.
And you can store--
like, the UV light
from the sun plus
the heat from the sun
also kills the pathogens and
bacteria inside the water.
If you remember-- do you
guys remember from last week
when we were playing
with the bags?
There was a SODIS bag.
Does that sound familiar at
all with the plastic sealer?
Yeah.
Why are you laughing?
AUDIENCE: Because we spent like
two hours trying to make one.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so SODIS
is a really cool technology.
It's an example
of how you can use
solar energy to purify water.
There are other ways you can
use solar energy to purify water
too, but this is supposed to
be one of the better ones.
So I guess we kind of
jumped ahead by showing you
a really good SODIS
technology last week
before talking to you about
SODIS as a technology.
But in most of the
developing world,
the companies that are
promoting SODIS, what they do
is they tell people to use
two liter bottles, which
are available in a lot
of the developing world,
and fill them with
water and leave them out
on your rooftops.
Can you guys think of
any ideas or any reasons
why this is not a good idea
or what isn't the best--
OK, why this isn't
the best solution
to using this technology
or best implementation
of this technology and why,
say, a bag would be better?
So what are some of the
problems with a plastic bottle?
So you have this plastic
bottle, looks kind of like that.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: We don't have the
perfect control [INAUDIBLE]
the bottle might topple over,
fall off, [INAUDIBLE] sit,
whereas the bag [INAUDIBLE]
bag was more just floppy.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
I actually haven't
seen that particular
issue before,
but that's a good point.
What about in terms
of transportation?
How easy is it to get a plastic
bottle that's shaped like this?
If I wanted to provide an
entire community with these,
how would I send it to them?
I would have to ship a giant
container with two liter
bottles, and they don't really
pack well at all, right?
You need to fill like a
crate of two liter bottles.
And it just seems really
silly to ship a container
of empty water bottles.
In places where they
have two liter bottles,
it's a really good
technology because, I mean,
if they're just taking existing
things that they already
have and they're using them,
repurposing them for this,
then it's great.
But otherwise, it doesn't
seem to make that much sense
to try to fly them in.
And that's what some
of the companies that
were really promoting SODIS
heavily in the beginning
were doing.
They were trying to ship
two liter bottles in bulk
to communities to
get them to use them.
Can you guys think of
any other disadvantages
to using these water bottles?
What about-- so how does--
OK, maybe I'll go
a little bit more
into how the technology works.
So you have your water
bottle like this, I guess.
That's not how it looks.
With your tapped water bottle,
it's filled with water.
Like, this is all water.
So what happens is you have
sunlight coming from here.
It's heating up the water.
It heat-- yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] also the
surface area of [INAUDIBLE]..
So I guess the water on the
bottom half of the bottle
will get [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so because
water and your plastic both
absorb some of the
sunlight, you have
a lot of it being
absorbed by this fluid.
And what they say is if this
depth is more than 4 inches,
that SODIS's effectiveness
is dropped by maybe 50%
I think is what they say.
So yeah, so that's
another problem.
I think a two liter bottle
is about the right size.
So still like in the
range of the right size.
So you're not going
to have over--
or you're not going to have
more than four inches there.
But that's definitely something
to take into consideration.
What about place-- so
what about the cap?
Can you guys think of why
the cap might be a problem?
AUDIENCE: It's not transparent.
So if you have any water
[INAUDIBLE] if you're
pouring water out [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
that's exactly, like,
one of the biggest problems with
SODIS with using a water bottle
is just because the region in
this area where the cap is just
doesn't--
I mean, it's opaque plastic.
So your UV rays are
getting-- or most of them
are getting blocked
by the plastic.
And so your bacteria don't
die necessarily over there.
So that's why the bag that
Shawn Frayne came up with,
the SODIS bag that you guys
saw the other time that
used two one way valves,
works a lot better
because the entire
thing is transparent.
And there was a
lot of work people
are trying to do
trying to redesign this
into a better system.
So they looked at the problems
with the transportation
with the two liter
bottle, and then they
came up with
another bag that was
kind of like just a bag
that had a handle here.
And then it had the same sort
of twist-on cap over here
that a two liter
bottle does, like that.
And then they made
the back of the bag
black so that it
would heat up more,
which is a pretty cool design.
But then we still
had problems with--
well, for one, having
expensive molded parts
is also really
expensive because--
and you can't really
fabricate that everywhere.
Like, you can't
go into a village
and try to create something
that looks like this or even
something that looks like this.
Whereas if you have a
simple plastic sealer,
you could make one of the SODIS
bags that we were working on
or that we saw last week.
Has anyone not seen the
SODIS bags from last week
or have no idea what
I'm talking about?
OK.
And how many of you have
heard of SODIS before?
OK.
So yeah, so this design sort
of went from this iteration
to this iteration.
And then Shawn Frayne came along
and worked on it a little bit
and came up with the
next iteration of--
or came up with his technology,
which is like really, really
good technology.
In terms of usage,
because I want
you guys to start thinking
about these technologies
and how you would
use them too, what's
another problem with this?
You're supposed to take this.
You're supposed to leave it
out in the sun for six hours,
and then it--
or six hours to
two days, depending
on the weather conditions.
And then it's supposed
to clean your water,
and you're supposed to drink it.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question on how it works.
What is it-- a chemical
inside the water to purify it?
PROFESSOR: No.
No, you just take water, right?
And you leave it out in the sun,
and the UV rays from the sun
kill the bacteria.
It breaks down the bacteria.
AUDIENCE: So any container?
PROFESSOR: Any container
as long as it's
clear and UV-transparent
or translucent.
AUDIENCE: What does
SODIS stand for?
PROFESSOR: Solar disinfection.
I should have explained that.
Yeah, sorry, you guys.
SODIS stands for
solar disinfection.
So you're purifying water
just using sunlight.
AUDIENCE: But is
there any company
that's going to market this?
PROFESSOR: It's a technique.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
AUDIENCE: It's not a product.
Yeah, it's just a technique.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: So then--
like, I know that BPAs
make water bottles are newest
hype because of all the toxins
that plastic releases
when it's in extreme heat,
like in extreme [INAUDIBLE]
or extreme [INAUDIBLE]
temperature.
Is that part of the
[INAUDIBLE] consideration?
The idea is that any
[INAUDIBLE] water
can be used for it exactly?
PROFESSOR: So generally,
leaching from plastic,
like, it's a problem that's on
a much smaller scale than having
unsafe drinking water.
And so if you had to choose
the trade-off between having
some plastic potentially
leach into your water
and drink it and en
like, dozens of years,
that might cause some health
problems versus having
unsafe drinking water,
like, you would definitely
choose unsafe--
or you definitely
choose the using SODIS
to drink your water.
But yeah, that is one of the
bigger concerns with SODIS.
Cool.
Are there any other
questions about SODIS?
All right, I'm going to
go into solar drying.
So solar drying is
another technology
that is used in a lot
of places in the world.
And the idea is basically that
you take fruit or whatever,
and you drive them so that
you can preserve them.
And the thing is,
in a lot of places,
you'll have farmers who
are growing something,
and they'll all have crops
that grow at the same time.
And so they'll harvest,
and then they'll
go take them to the market.
And because there's
an overabundance
of these fruits or
something, people
aren't getting their peak.
Like, they're not
getting as much money
as they can for their
fruits because there's way
too much of-- like, there's
way more supply than there's
a demand for it.
And they don't have
a very good way
of preserving food otherwise.
So they can't
refrigerate these fruits.
So if they don't keep
them refrigerated,
then they're just
going to spoil.
So it's either
sell at a low cost
or don't get anything for them.
And so their food preservation
is a pretty big deal as well.
And so you can use solar
energy to also dry fruits.
And this is a project
called Fruits of the Nile
that works in Uganda,
where they do that.
And then I'm going
to go to talking
about solar thermal
panels for water heating.
I don't know if you
guys have seen these.
These are taken from
the US, these pictures.
But do any of you have
exposure to solar thermal?
Yeah, so what you're basically
doing here is you have--
well, there are two
types of systems which
I guess are on the next slide.
So you have two different
types of systems.
But this is a little
bit more complicated
than it needs to be.
So basically, the idea is
you're taking in sunlight.
And using the sunlight, you're
heating water or some of fluid.
And so you have sort of
this container that's
shaped like this,
or you have tubes
that have water or some
container or something running
it through it.
Sunlight hits this
container, heats up
the water inside these tubes.
And then you store the
hot water in a tank.
So that's a direct
solar thermal system.
There's also indirect
solar thermal systems
where instead of having your
water being heated directly,
you have a heat exchanger here.
And then you have some of fluid
that goes through the system.
And then you have your
reservoir or something.
And what's hitting the water
is just like hot fluid-- like,
the heat exchanger.
So it's heating the water.
A heat exchanger
is just something
that transfers heat from
one thing to another
if you were wondering.
And so there's a lot of--
solar thermal is way less
efficient than solar PV,
photovoltaics.
But it's also
significantly cheaper.
I don't have numbers
for you for that,
but you don't want to
think of solar thermal
as only being a small
scale technology
because there are large scale
applications of it as well.
This is sort of like
the smallest case,
you can think of.
It would be like having one
of these for your household
to heat water for showering
or something like that.
And then you have
larger scale versions
of this too, which is the Luz
Project in the Mojave Desert.
And it's the largest solar
thermal electric installation
in the world.
It has 350 megawatt peak output.
And you can see,
like, this picture.
Those are three people
standing next to it.
So this thing is massive.
It's on the order of kilometers.
Yeah, and the way this works
is it's similar to this
except you have your pipes
that have water in them.
But then you have these
concentrating troughs
that are focusing all of
the sunlight onto the pipes.
And so with the way
this technology works
is you heat up
water to the point
where it turns into
steam, and then you
have the steam power a turbine.
And then you produce
electricity using that.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I taught they
used oil in the pipes.
PROFESSOR: Wait, what?
AUDIENCE: They use
oil in the pipes.
PROFESSOR: Oh, they use oil?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, they use
oil through the pipes
to bring to the
general community.
PROFESSOR: Did you do research?
AUDIENCE: I did solar energy
consulting this past summer
at DLA.
So we looked at the energy
problems with CSP power plants
in the US.
It was really cool.
AUDIENCE: What does
it [INAUDIBLE]??
The thermal part I get, but
what would the electrical be?
AUDIENCE: Those
power plants are used
for [INAUDIBLE] generation.
PROFESSOR: So--
AUDIENCE: Oh, I see.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So these
generate electricity.
Yeah.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So you have steam,
which powers a turbine.
And that turbine
generates electricity.
And so not only do you have--
yeah, like, you're not
doing something simple
like heating water anymore.
You're also using
the same technology,
but now you're generating
electricity from it.
And I thought I would
throw this in just for fun.
This was another cool--
like, this is a
project that I was
working on last year in Brazil.
And it's a really low
cost solar water heater.
But the reason I
threw this in was
because a way a lot of these
lower cost cheaper ones work
is they work based
off of a thermosiphon.
And so basically what
happens is when you have--
what happens is in
a system like this,
you'll have a system like this
that's connected to a tank.
And so water heats up in this.
And as water heats up,
like, if you remember from--
I guess you learned
this in middle school.
Hot air rises-- like,
things like that.
So hot water also rises.
So you got a flow of water
towards the top of this thing.
So what happens is if you
connect this to a reservoir,
you'll get an--
you basically get a flow
caused just by the temperature
differentiable in the water.
So hot water will rise,
flow into this reservoir,
and it'll get displaced
by cold water.
And so you're regulating
the temperature
and heating all of the
water consistently,
which is pretty cool because
with a system that's based off
of a thermosiphon,
you don't need
to throw in a pump or
something like that to extract
the water from your--
yes.
AUDIENCE: What's
the [INAUDIBLE]??
Is it a heat siphon?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's
just a heat siphon.
But yeah, so it's just a passive
way of doing the same flow.
I'm going to go into--
are there any questions on
any of what I've talked about?
I know I did, like, a really,
really cursory job if you
transfer earlier, but that's
because we're going to go more
into it when we were talking
about photovoltaics and more
next week when you're
going into conductance
and convection for cooking.
But are there any
other questions
that you guys have about
what we just talked about?
OK, so we're going to
move on to photovoltaics.
I'm going to try to explain
to you how solar cells work.
I got-- a lot of
this information
was taken from this
website called pveducation.
It actually used to
be called PVCDROM,
which I thought was pretty funny
because it's a website now.
So I guess it's been
around for a while.
Are you familiar with this?
Yeah, OK, .
It's a great resource for a lot
of information that you might--
it'll answer a lot of
the questions you have,
and it does a pretty
good job of keeping
its level, like, basic
enough for you to understand
plus being mathy enough for
you to actually understand
what's going on too if
you're interested in that.
So let's start by saying
you should go on that
and read up on more of
it want if you have time
and you are inclined to learn
more about how photovoltaics
work.
But anyway, the
temperature of the sun--
does anyone know what the
temperature of the sun is?
About--
AUDIENCE: Isn't it 10,000
Kelvin or something?
PROFESSOR: That's a little high.
AUDIENCE: Like 1 million Kelvin?
PROFESSOR: That's
a little higher.
It's less than-- it's
about 6,000 Kelvin.
AUDIENCE: 60?
PROFESSOR: 6,000.
Well-- so to be fair,
when you have the--
so you have the sun, and
it's kind of like that.
You have the core, where
there's fusion going on.
And I think the core temperature
is maybe like 20 million
Kelvin or something like that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So
something like that.
It's something
ridiculously high.
I might be off by an
order or two of magnitude
in some direction.
But it's not really
that important.
But what happens is
most of that energy
is blocked off by the sort of
dense hydrogen around here.
And then you have
the very end of--
you have, like, the outer
rim of the sun, which
is at about 6,000 Kelvin,
which is what's radiating
most of the heat to the Earth.
And so that's where we get
all of our energy from.
It's kind of cool to look at
a graph of what the energy--
of what the
irradiance looks like.
So this is what wavelengths--
so this is a weird graph.
The red, green, and blue
are three different types
of lighting, and the
purple is what the sun is.
So you can ignore
the other three,
but you should
look at the purple
to see what wavelengths of
light the sun outputs at.
It's interesting because you
can see that-- this is also
on a log scale.
So you can see that
the bulk of the light
is in the visible spectrum,
which is cool because--
yeah.
And to measure how much energy
is being outputted by the sun,
you can just integrate
under this curve
to measure the entire thing.
Do you guys know what the
energy from a single photon
is based off of the wavelength?
Do you remember the
equations for that?
So you can calculate--
did someone say it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: It's Planck's
constant times c over lambda.
So you have this.
You don't need to
know this equation,
but it'll give you
a good sense of how
you can derive
how much energy is
coming from a photon or a wave.
So this is Planck's constant.
This is the speed of light,
and this is the wavelength.
And so what's
important from this
is that the lower
the wavelength,
the more energy you have.
So yeah, your blue
light is going
to have more energy
than your red light.
Does that make sense?
Cool.
So you have this.
So you have your sun.
It's outputting.
So you have the sun,
which you're looking at,
as radiating a bunch of
electromagnetic waves
in the form of, I guess, photons
to the Earth, which is here.
And then we were trying
to look at what happens.
Like, if we're trying to follow
the path of this radiation,
we can see that not all of
it reaches the Earth or not
all of it that reaches
the Earth makes it
to the surface of the
Earth because a lot of it
is absorbed by our atmosphere.
And so this is a kind of
graphic that'll show you
where a lot of energy is lost.
So only about 70% of it is
actually directed to the Earth.
3% is scattered
to space, and 18%
is absorbed by the atmosphere.
Now we're going to go into
how a solar cell works.
So yeah, OK.
So this is also a
little bit complicated.
So you have a solar cell,
which looks like this
if you haven't seen one before.
They're super fragile.
We can pass them around.
These are broken ones.
Evergreen solar was kind enough
to donate 200 of these duds
for this lab and
for our projects.
So we'll be playing with them
and wiring them up today.
So are you-- what happened?
AUDIENCE: I wanted to
put my thumbprint on it,
and I broke the slide.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
they're super fragile.
You can see why--
it's one of the reasons why
working with solar cells
is such a pain because
they're so easy to break.
Like, you have to solder them
together to make them work.
So it's kind of difficult.
We'll get into that later.
So how do they work?
So you basically have two
layers in your solar cell
as is described in this drawing.
And what happens is you
have a photon coming in.
And for one, they're
a semiconductor.
So who can tell me what
a semiconductor is?
OK, have-- yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
And you have to have
exactly the right bandgap
in between the two so that
when a photon hits it,
when a photon hits on it, it
activates exactly what you
need to [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's correct.
Yeah, did everyone
understand that?
OK, so basically, what
happens is in a semiconductor,
you have things in a
pretty ordered pattern.
So you'll have, like,
atom, something like that.
And so they're all bent
but bound in the slightest.
And so what happens is they
don't have free electrons right
now, but you can get a
free electron from them
if you excite the electron
with enough energy.
And so if you have a photon
coming in and it has the right
amount of energy to excite an
electron out of one of these
bonds, then the
valence electron--
or out of the lattice--
the electron becomes excited.
And you then get an
electron hole pair.
And this is all a
gross simplification
of how this works because
a lot of this is--
like, I mean, you can't
really just think of--
you can think of
electrons as particles
that are moving
across a circuit,
but that's not
actually how it works.
But for this, you're
going to assume
this simplification makes
sense to try to conceptually
understand how it works.
So what happens is have
a photon hitting this.
So you get this
electron hole pair.
And you can think of a hole as
where the electron was before.
And so now there's this space
where this electron was.
And so it's kind
of a positive area
because there's less electron.
Like, there's no
electron there anymore.
So you can think of it kind
of like a bubble in a fluid
almost.
And so this electron wants
to go back into this bubble,
and this bubble is free to move
as well just like the electron
is, free to move
through the structure
now because it
can go through it.
And so what happens is if you--
but the thing is that you're
using two different types
of silicon, and one of them
is an n type, and one of them
is a p type.
And the n and p just stand
for negative and positive.
And so the other thing
is you can dope silicon.
And what that means is
you put impurities in it,
and that creates a
permanent electric field
inside the silicon.
And so one of your sides is
more positive, and one of them
is more negative.
So when you create this
electron hole pair here,
they're going to
want to be pulled
towards opposite directions
just based off of drift.
And so once they get
pulled to either side,
if you create a circuit and
you put a load on this thing,
then you can have the
electron flow through here
and go back into the holes here.
Then it'll close the circuit
again and combine with the--
yeah, so that's a
very simplified way
of how photovoltaics work.
Does that make sense to people?
Are there any
questions about that?
AUDIENCE: So the
positive [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: No, the n type
should be the negative.
AUDIENCE: Huh?
PROFESSOR: The n
type is negative.
AUDIENCE: There's a really
good animation [INAUDIBLE]
that shows the two different
types of the [INAUDIBLE]
electron.
PROFESSOR: That's true.
We could actually just watch it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I had it opening.
PROFESSOR: OK, yeah.
Anyway, so that's basically
how photovoltaics work.
You get-- yes.
AUDIENCE: Doesn't sunlight
hit the junction, though?
Isn't that how--
I mean, because you
have the holes and then
the electrons on the side
creating the opposite pole
electric field.
Doesn't light hit the middle?
I mean, that was
my understanding.
I may be wrong, but I
thought it hit the middle.
PROFESSOR: I'm not sure.
That's not how I understood it.
So the reason-- so the
absorption coefficient
of silicon is really low.
So you have a lot of
different solar cells, right?
You have amorphous silicon.
You have multi-crystalline
silicon and stuff.
And the reason why--
you have thin film
cells as well.
But the reason why
silicon cells are so thick
is because the absorption
coefficient is so low
that you basically
need a thicker
area to be able to
absorb most of the light.
I'm not answering
your question, am I?
You think that--
AUDIENCE: So my
understanding was
that it would hit the middle--
like, not exactly the middle.
But you know how
like in the middle,
you have the opposite
electric field?
Because of the holes in
the electrons on the sides?
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: So if this is
your n and your peak,
then you'd have volts here,
and you have electrons here
from the opposite field.
And my understanding was
that it would hit the middle,
and the field would
force the electrons
to go in one direction,
which would then be used to--
then we helped it by
an external circuit.
PROFESSOR: Well, there
are few factors in play.
So you have one side that has--
here, I can show
you a video on how--
OK, I don't know
if this will work.
So this is from this
PVCDROM website.
And so it's an animation
saying how things work.
And so if you have a
moderate field, you have--
so you have two things at work.
You have diffusion.
And the thing is, diffusion,
the way diffusion works
is if you have a lot of--
I mean, it just--
if you have a lot
of holes on one side
and electrons on the
other, the electrons
want to tend to go to the side
where there aren't electrons,
and the holes want to
tend to go to the side
where there aren't holes.
And so you have that,
but that's working
against the positive
and negative factor of--
or the positive and negative
charges of the two sides
as well.
So you have those two kind
of balancing each other out
in some way.
So-- I'm really
confused by this.
So what you have--
hold on.
OK, yeah.
So once you're connecting
this to a load,
you're now enabling
the holes and electrons
to travel across this
conductive region too.
And so they're not
only-- like, now they're
not just diffusing and
drifting through here.
They're also, like,
traveling through.
Does that not-- that's not
answering your question?
AUDIENCE: So basically,
I understand the concept.
I was just curious whether,
like, in the diagram,
you know how there's-- you
know the middle region,
the depletion right there?
My understanding was that's
where the electrons were.
I mean, that's
where the light hit,
and that's where the
electrons were ejected.
And then they would move around.
But I mean, this diagram
doesn't seem to be doing this.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I'm pretty
sure that the light creates
electron hole pairs anywhere
inside the entire cell.
But I can double check with you
and follow up on that as well.
Cool, so now, we're
going to go into
some practical considerations
for developing world
work in solar.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So solar panels
can't function past 15 years
or something like that.
What exactly is breaking down
in this to cause that time?
PROFESSOR: I'm not really sure.
AUDIENCE: They often function
a lot more than 15 years
[INAUDIBLE].
I think most of them
have to do with actually
not the cells themselves but
the glass on the [INAUDIBLE]
or something breaking down,
getting scratches and dirty,
[INAUDIBLE].
I think a lot of the
panels are actually
outlasting their warranties.
[INAUDIBLE] have like
25 years [INAUDIBLE]..
I think some of the
earlier [INAUDIBLE]
are still operating
well past that.
AUDIENCE: So there's nothing
chemical going on with this?
AUDIENCE: It might
be a little bit,
but that's not
really the biggest.
It's mostly, yeah,
the glasses are
getting dirty and scratched.
PROFESSOR: I can also look that
up and get back to you on that.
Yeah, so let's look at some
of the financial tools that
are available in order
to finance solar.
So you can do the four sort
of big ones are microfinance,
a fee for service, income
generation, or smaller systems
and then see how for
microfinance, you
have smaller payments over
a longer period of time.
For fee for service, you have
a company that owns a PV system
and a household that pays
the electric bill for it.
For income generation,
which we saw,
I think, in the lighting
lecture last week,
we saw how people were
using solar panels
to generate income.
You use a system to improve
your income stream so you can--
with something like this,
you'll have one person
with a lot of solar panels who
will charge a lot of batteries
and rent them out
as electricity.
And then for
smaller systems, you
can scale the technology down.
So you're not using the
giant solar panels anymore,
but you're using
smaller solar panels
to power lantern or something
like that, for example.
Yeah, and so that
was the bulk of what
I wanted to talk about
today about solar cells.
I guess one of the
interesting things
to note about them
is that it's weird
because their technology
is that's very much--
there's a quote
from Harish Hande,
who is the founder
of SELCO, that's
solar is expensive for the rich
and affordable for the poor.
It's the rich who
need subsidies.
And it's this weird
thing because electricity
for the amount that people need
in the developing world for,
the amount of energy
that they need
there, solar is a very
cheap solution for that
whereas the amount of
electricity that we're
using at like at the
scales we're looking at,
solar is a very
expensive option compared
to other sorts of electricity.
So it's pretty important.
Like, it's pretty
important to think about--
or it's important to
think of solar is not
an expensive technology per
se because I think in the US,
at least, we have that bias
as solar being expensive.
And SELCO makes
profit because they
sell all their solar panels
without subsidies at all.
So I thought that
was pretty cool.